-You mentioned that you had
never played tennis before.
Obviously, you´re playing
a woman who not only played,
but we know from your experience
at the U.S. Open,
will tell you what she thinks
about your playing.
-Exactly.
-And I heard that you
actually developed --
´Cause you didn´t
have to learn
how to play tennis.
You had to learn
how to play old tennis.
-Like Billie Jean, exactly.
Wooden-rackets ´70s tennis.
Which, one time,
I was actually at a public court
learning with a trainer,
and these guys were next to us,
and they were like,
"Oh, tight. Huh.
Wooden rackets.
That´s pretty cool."
And I was like,
"I´m not being a hipster.
I´m just learning
this form of tennis for work.
But all right."
I mean, I guess people do play
wooden-racket tennis probably.
-Yeah, oh, I´m sure
there´s plenty of dickheads
in New York that are like,
"I´m gonna play with my old
Jimmy Connors racket."
-It´s hard.
-I would imagine it´s hard.
And you´re starting
from a place where you --
I mean,
maybe it was easier for you
because you didn´t have to
unlearn modern tennis.
-No, exactly.
And it was kind of fun.
Because at the end of my
lessons, once I got a little --
Once I started understanding
a little bit more,
I would get to play for five
minutes with a modern-day racket
and a different grip, and
I was like, "I can really hit!
-Yeah.
-Whoa!"
But before that, it was just
my trainer was having to come up
with choreography names
to teach me.
So it was like, you know,
there´s a shot that´s like this,
and that was called the "olé."
And then a volley was,
"Serve the pizza!
Serve the pizza!"
And he would just shout at me
from across the court.
"Serve the pizza! Run! Olé!"
And I was like --
It was really --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This is --
-I just wanted to do her proud.
-You just wanted
to do her proud.
She seemed very proud of you
yesterday.
So I think mission accomplished.
-I also had an amazing double,
so things were good.
-But let´s give the credit
where credit is due.
-Yeah. Full disclosure.
-This is your
second movie with Steve.
-Yes.
-But this movie
is your third movie --
-This is my third movie
with Fred Armisen.
-Fred Armisen!
-It´s true.
-Three movies with Fred.
-Yeah. Three movies.
-What were your -- What were
your other movies with Fred?
-Fred, what were
our other movies?
-It was "The Rocker," right?
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-"Easy A", and this one.
-Wow. That´s great.
Three with Fred.
-We´ve known each other
for so long, Fred.
-We´re like a movie duo.
-Yeah.
-I guess you could say it´s
our ten-year friend-iversary.
-Yeah, that´s really great.
-Did you get us anything?
-Uhh...
I got you Fred´s
Ninjago character.
-Yes!
That´s what I was hoping for!
-That´s cool. That´s cool.
-This rocks.
-I´m going bring it
to the...
-Great. Thank you.
-Anytime.
-I want to ask you about this.
Because you have obviously
been doing this a long time.
You´ve known Fred for ten years.
-Ten years.
-That speaks to your time
in the business.
Is it true that you, at one
point, tried writing a script?
Like a television script?
-I don´t understand how you guys
found out this information.
-We found out --
So I know it´s true.
So now I´m basically giving you
an opportunity to either
admit it or lie to me.
-It´s true. It´s true.
-It´s true.
-I was homeschooled
in middle school.
And I got to take a kind of
screenwriting English class.
And so I wrote an episode,
a "lost episode,"
of "Mad About You"
as a spec script,
where Paul Reiser
meets Paul McCartney.
And I believe it was called
"The Tale of Two Pauls."
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-And now I have -- I do not
remember "Mad About You"
being a show that middle
schoolers were super into.
-I was so into "Mad About You."
That´s so great.
You were just a middle schooler
who was like,
"If I could write for anyone,
it´d be Paul Reiser."
-It was --
His delivery is fantastic.
I was like,
"I know he´ll nail this."
-Um, I think --
If we ever get
both Pauls in town,
I´d love to do a reading of it.
-All right. That sounds great.
But I don´t know how to find it.
That´s crazy.
I lost it, I guess.
That´s so weird.
-Check under your
spelling-bee trophy.
I think it´s probably there.
-Okay.
I just folded it up.
And those are what I keep.
My specs script, my trophy.
-Thanks so much
for being here, Emma.
It´s such a delight
to see you, as always.
-It´s great to see you.
-Emma Stone!